So please welcome Marley Dias,
everybody!
-♪ ♪
-(cheering and applause)
Marley!
-Hey, Marley!
-Nice to meet you.
Have a seat right here.
I know. Awesome.
Uh, so great to have you here.
-Thank you.
-Such a cool story.
So, you were reading, uh,
stories about white boys
-and their dogs. Right?
-Yes.
So explain that to me,
how that inspired you.
So, it really did,
because I was reading, um,
Where the Red Fern Grows
by Wilson Rawls,
I was reading the Shiloh series,
and I read Old Yeller,
-and, basically, Where the...
-Right. Old Yeller,
-really, really sad. Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, it is.
But I read, um, Where the Red
Fern Grows, and that's about
a boy who saves his money
to buy a dog to help him hunt.
And then the Shiloh series
is about a boy who finds a dog
-and uses him on a farm. And Old
Yeller is about a boy -Right.
-who finds a dog and
then uses him on a farm. -Yeah.
So they were all really
the same.
-But I noticed that when I went
home and read the books -Yeah.
that I wanted to, like,
about black girls,
they were all different. Like,
sometimes I was reading about
student council. Sometimes
I was reading about a girl
who went to Africa.
So it was always different.
-It was never, like, the same
plot I was hearing over -Yeah.
-and over. -And these books
weren't in your schools.
-They weren't in my school, no.
-Right. Man, interesting.
-And-and your name is Marley.
That's such a cool name. -Yes.
-Were you named after Bob
Marley? Really? -Yes, my mother
is Jamaican, so she named me
after Bob Marley.
Wow, that is amazing,
'cause it's-it's ironic...
-(cheering and applause)
-Well, they're clapping.
What's ironic to me is
that there's actually a movie
called Marley and Me
about a white boy and his dog.
-Yes, I know.
-It's kind of ironic, you know?
Have you ever thought
of collecting 1,000 movies
and giving them out to schools?
Yes. That would be an idea.
So let me ask you a question.
So why do you think
it is important to read a book
with someone who's like you?
Like, what was it that really
made that important to you?
Well, it really was because when
you read a story about a person
that you can connect with...
So, like, you host a TV show.
-Yeah. -So, if you were to read
a book about a black man
who hosts a TV show,
then you would remember
-whatever he learned so you
could use it on the show. -What?
-Could you go collect some
of those books, maybe? -Yes.
Could the, uh... could the black
late-night host have a dog?
Maybe, yeah. If you want.
Um, how-how surprised were you
that there were so many books?
'Cause you collected... How
many books have you collected?
-Uh, about 1,000. -Were
you surprised how many books
-there were out there?
-Yes. I knew that there was
a lot of children's books,
because when you're a kid,
they push reading so much,
for you to learn all that stuff.
But when you get older, like,
books become, like, scarce,
and you only read
normally one type.
So I was like, "Whoa, I didn't
know that I was missing out
on so many books in my school."
But... Because when I get older,
I just kind of have to read
book club books about white boys
and their dogs, and it just
kind of... it becomes, like,
-all of my day. So... -I bet
there's a book club out there.
"All right, this is the White
Boy, Dog Book Club, everybody.
Uh, today's book,
White Boy and His Dog."
Have you...
What has been the action...
the reaction with
your classmates and everything?
-Well, they've been really proud
of me. -Oh, cool.
So they've been, like,
high-fiving me and saying,
"Congrats on your 1,000.
I hope you get 1,000 more."
So they've been
really supportive for me.
Have any white boys with dogs
congratulated you?
-Yes, actually, they have.
-Really?
Because sometimes they're sick
of reading those stories, too.
That's hilarious.
They're like, "Finally!
-Finally, a different story!"
-Yeah.
That's great. Um...
Uh, now, it's interesting,
'cause, uh,
I love the selflessness
of what you're doing.
-Thank you. -You know, you...
you're getting all these books
and you're giving them all away,
you know,
-finding homes for them.
Have you ever, uh, -Yeah.
found, uh, any books
that you really wanted to keep
-or hang on to?
-Yes. Like, half of them.
You haven't secretly,
like, pssh, like,
-put 'em under your bed, that
kind of thing? -May... Maybe.
Really? Seriously?
-Yeah.
-It's just between us.
-Yeah. -What-what
was one of your favorites?
Well, my favorite-- I have read
it-- it's Brown Girl Dreaming
-by Jacqueline Woodson.
So, it's a... -Oh, nice.
like, a book in poetry form
about a girl who lives
in the 1960s and '70s during Jim
Crow laws and stuff like that.
And she talks about her life
in South Carolina and New York
-and how it's different and her
family. -Well, that's awesome.
Look, Marley, we... you know,
we love to keep it 100 here
on this show. Or as I like
to say, keep it "a-hunned."
Right? So... And you've kept it
100 more than anyone
in the community, so
we're giving you our brand-new
-Keep It 100 Gold Award here.
-Oh, my God! Thank you!
Keep It 100.
It's our highest honor.
-On behalf of The Nightly Show,
I want -Thank you so much.
to give you the first ever
golden 100. Right there.
And this is for
your-your school administrators
who didn't have those books.
They get a lot of weak tea.
-Right there.
You can give that to 'em. -Okay.
On behalf of The Nightly Show,
weak tea, okay?
-Thank you.
-Please give it to them.
-Marley Dias, everybody!
-Thank you!
Marley, thank you so much! Thank
you so much for joining us!